hey how's it going friends my name is
Peter Potts
today we got booty man sorry I got a
little too excited let's just play the
game I don't know anything about this
game don't look at me like that I don't
know anything about the game put on some
headphones and lock the door cuz we're
gonna have some fun baby we're gonna
play hard because I'm not a little [ __ ]
okay so quick tips that's always good
thank you thank you note that appeared
right in front of my face boogeyman has
four ways of getting into the room
listen for the unique noises made from
each oh god I
I literally just skipped all the other
he's really good at crawling in vents
okay so here we are I'm sitting on a
toilet oh god I'm so tiny I'm a little
kid ah daddy daddy please
daddy I can't reach the potty
hello Oh God oh jeez this is bad
hey Rick I don't think we need to do
this hold F Thank You text Oh God
press F to enter Knight walnuts okay
daddy
thank God we had the night lamp what oh
look at the bed alright oh if you're
listening to this I sure hope you're not
planning on sleeping in this room I am
Alyssia and if you've unfortunately only
somebody across the states you in a dark
it's probably watching you right now
I left a flashlight under the bed if
you've not already found it oh I've
tried telling people but the bogeyman
Eagle my sister no one will believe me
they won't believe you either trust me
you'll need to learn to fight this by
yourself there's some spare batteries
hidden under the floorboard under the
bed
I believe you learn like it could mean
where's that coming from
what the [ __ ] this is creepiest [ __ ] man
I got a survivor all night at least time
is going fast I suppose Oh
oh my god I can not I need another
battery I'm running out of battery man
oh boy
it sucks being a pity pot cuz I'm
running out of battery then hate why
what the [ __ ] is going on I'm sweating
and it's itching me Oh what was that
but the window hey Teddy I love you
you're my man you got a grey hat Teddy
what was I what's that on the bed oh
it's the window it's the window Rose I
don't think we're gonna make it out god
I'm sweat are you sweating - god dammit
[ __ ] man
this is terrifying I don't like this I
don't like it one bit
hello I'm trying to open my ears this is
already better than fine nights at
freddys 4 sorry I'm not sorry
hey it's an owl shut the [ __ ] up can
Timmy get a little bit of rest in here
Timmy hasn't slept all night
Timmy's gotta go up and go to work
tomorrow oh god what is that Gothic Rob
I prefer we wake up at 7:00 right I mean
the Sun is up in like 6 or something
right Oh God always saved we're saved
hallelujah praise the Jesus yes
we're dead a hot [ __ ]
oh my god next night I suppose I need to
find my flashlight and get back to the
room [ __ ] mom oh where the [ __ ] oh god
oh [ __ ]
all the doors are lying oh I gotta hold
it down
oh my god he was waiting for me what a
[ __ ] ah I can't I Peter law what is
this the room oh god what was that I'm
gonna I'm gonna get [ __ ] for this you
know
no I saw him I saw him what do they say
whispers to me but I need to leave the
house
he's a such a sneaky [ __ ] all the
[ __ ] noise says shut up I hate you I
love you better not be in here he is in
there how about how do you how many are
there a teleporting oh my god we got the
flashlight alright we're gonna go back
now gotta go back to bed don't attack me
whoa
J yes um this banana this banana made me
do it
yeah oh I feel good what happened hey
[ __ ] I hate this is so creepy
that my mom what Oh [ __ ] Oh
oh [ __ ] him like this
oh god what was that sound oh god what
was that [ __ ] thing I like my
mustache when I'm nervous all right what
do you [ __ ] do you one from mother [ __ ]
what's that [ __ ] was that
hey guys just chill
what just happen you know what it's time
to stop that's adorable how cute that is
reminds me of Edgar when it wasn't such
a little [ __ ] oh my god that that is
adorable
ha ha ha can I oh my god can I just do
this instead instead of all these
[ __ ] horror games can I just do this
well anyway thank you for watching this
video if you enjoyed please leave a like
I really appreciate it and as always
stay awesome bros I didn't even blink
let's do a replay on that [ __ ]
your pizza's here